e aí
eu nasci sem saber o que era poesia
passei a infância brincando na rua à
noite aves tava o clarão da lua eu ia
para casa deitar vai dormir mas eu nunca
tive uma assessoria que me desse algo a
complementar não tive ensino para vir da
clamar não fui para a escola que forma
poeta aprender aos poucos essa é minha
meta para fazer galope na beira do mar
eu sou é da terra do maior são joão que
tem nosso mestre que é vitalino do
bairro cumpriu com seu destino do alto
do moura o maior tesão mas sua partida
partiu o coração que quando se lembram
começam chorar mas aquele povo daquele
lugar sabe que ele está com o pai fiel
olhando para gente em cima do céu
fazendo boneca na beira do mar viva
vitalino vivo o alto do moura certa
época eu tinha 8 anos de idade
e eu tive que esperar 25 anos para mim
poder me reconectar e realmente me
conhecer e conhecer minha identidade e
poder correr atrás dos meus sonhos e
tudo isso que o poder uma pessoa um
professor
e quando eu tinha 8 anos de idade eu
escutei pela primeira vez uma poesia
popular através do poeta amazan que meu
pai comprou uma fita cassete e aí a
gente escutou e rapidamente com poucos
dias eu acabei decorando todas aquelas
poesias poesias de sete seis cinco
minutos poesias longas mas eram poesias
engraçadas falava justamente da vida
cotidiana do nordestino do poeta do
matuto nordestino eram rimadas e
justamente falava esse linguajar da
gente linguajar arrastado né do matuto
realmente e aí o toda oportunidade que
eu tinha estava declamando poesia eu me
senti bem fazendo aquilo sabe isso era
na escola espera na frente de casa nas
reuniões de família eu tava sempre
declamando porque menino quando aprendi
uma coisa novo cê sabe como é né ou eu
pensei em fazer olha ei e aí eu sair
daqui eu mando poesia mas aí a gente
começou a trabalhar e com 12 anos eu
lembro que eu comecei a vender picolé na
rua
como fazer cocada fazia dudu e me botar
para vender e aí as vezes eu saio com
vergonha né com medo de encontrar alguém
ou alguns dos colegas de escola porque
eu já fazia parte do time de futsal e
meu sonho era ser jogador de futebol
esse sempre foi meu sonho e aí então
acho que uns 15 anos eu entrei em fiz
uma peneira aqui no clube do central
sport club acabei passando acho que
tinha 1.200 1100 alunos e eu passei
entre os dez melhores aí eu digo agora
eu vou ser jogador de futebol essa é a
esse é o caminho só que meus pais se
separaram e aí eu tive que realmente ter
um compromisso maior com o trabalho que
teve uma responsabilidade maior foi
quando eu 19 anos entrei no meu primeiro
trabalho de carteira assinada e aí
comecei a trabalhar em uma loja
especializada em tecnologia eu fui
técnico de informática durante 13 anos
no ramo de montagem e manutenção de
microcomputadores
oi e o sonho ser jogador de futebol já
foi esse penteado
bom e com isso
e eu conheci o teatro
o grupo teatro me apresentei muito aqui
neste palco principalmente com a comédia
chamada deu a louca no convento onde eu
fazia um papel de uma freira eu era a
reverenda madre eu acho que alguns aqui
já assistiram era uma peça muito muito
engraçada elas agora eu vou ser ator
é mas aí com o passar do tempo eu deixei
um pouco de lado do teatro e eu
precisava me exercitar porque desde
pequeno sempre joguei bola corri sempre
era bem fisicamente e aí eu conheci o
box
oi e aí com poucos dias com poucos anos
do no as atividades esportivas no box e
o professor disse olha tem um evento ali
para você não tá você quer eu digo eu
quero eu sempre fui muito competitivo
sabe desde pequena eu sempre fui aquele
cara que gostava de apostar às vezes eu
chamava 22 colegas de rua aposta para
mim jogar sozinho contra os dois dizem
que ganhava e aí a gente fazer aquela
aquela porta e aí eu era muito
competitivo e com eu disse eu quero
professor quero fazer a luta e eu tive
que perder dentro de um mês 8 kg porque
eu tava com 70kg e eu precisava chegar
na categoria de 62 kg aí eu perdi perdi
rapidamente esses quilos com muita
dedicação com muita vontade mas só que
na hora da luta eu acabei perdendo eu
acabei perdendo para o pontos acabei me
lesionando também porque no box a gente
movimenta muito braço e acabei batendo
muito no meu apolete e acabei me
lesionando e aí eu deixei de treinar eu
disse quando eu melhorar eu volto e não
voltei mais
oi e aí certa vez vai conversando com
minha esposa a gente falando sobre
perspectiva de vida não é o que a gente
pensaria pro futuro aí minha esposa
olhou para mim disse mas tu já observou
como é tua vida nas redes sociais dá uma
olhadinha só para tu ter uma noção aí eu
fui observar realmente de baixo para
cima eu observei que eu tava vivendo de
fases sabe a cada seis meses eu fazer
uma coisa a seis meses eu jogava bola
seis meses e depois eu queria ser
jogador de blocks lutador de boxe depois
você já leu de futebol e nada tomava um
rumo
a ave se realmente eu tô vivendo de
fases claro que sou o momento importante
os momentos bons que eu tava gostando
mas tô vivendo de fases até que certo
dia a gente trabalhando no são joão de
caruaru eu e minha esposa a gente
trabalhava na casa do forró e na frente
da casa do forró tinha a casa do cordel
oi e o certa noite a gente foi
descansado isso vamos descansar na casa
do cordel e o administrador da casa eu
conheço nelson lima um grande ator e
assim que eu entrei na casa do cordel
tinha um camarada no palco da tua mãe
uma poesia de quem
o poeta amazan e ali na hora que eu
parei eu digo para que massa eu conheço
essa poesia e aí eu parei sabe e me veio
aquela fita me veio aqueles oito anos de
idade aí eu digo para isso que eu tenho
que fazer velho chamei né o sinal só
posso declamar uma poesia também né os
franziu a testa e disse pode né
e eu fui daqui a meio quando o cara saiu
daquela minha poesia eu não sou beijo né
dentro da mesma coisa engraçada que o
pessoal realmente tal quando eu daquela
minha poesia o pessoal veio aí poeta de
goiás já poeta cara que massa quiser eu
tirar foto comigo eu digo tô gostando
quando eu cheguei para nelson nelson
disse é essa frase impacto deus diz cara
eu não conhecia esse teu lado eu disse
nelson nem eu
e aí ele disse você já tem algum cordel
publicado eu disse eu não sei nem como é
que faz
e ele me segurou no braço e disse forma
aprender
oi e aí são dois anos com a literatura
de cordel levando sendo instrumento ser
essa ferramenta de da arte da cultura
graças ao cordel hoje eu tenho oito
cordéis publicados tem mais alguns ainda
em fabricação falta só a correção mas eu
tenho feito comerciais levando a
literatura de cordel eu tenho recebido
convites de grandes emissoras afiliadas
de grandes emissoras do país aqui de
caruaru que ligam para mim diz o cara
tem esse tema tu tem como fazer
e tem e aí eu não deixa de ser
competitivo sabe porque quando eu era
quando eu jogava e quando eu treinava
não tava box objetivos realmente das da
competição é você vê se o outro planeta
na literatura de cordel tô sempre
lutando comigo mesmo sabe porque eu tô
fazendo eu tô escrevendo cordel de temas
de que eu não tenho propriedade do qual
não tenho realmente né aquela
massificação de conhecimento de ali eu
vou atrás eu vou pesquisar eu vou
procurar saber eu vou ter todo o
conhecimento para poder realmente
transformar essa história e literatura
de cordel e eu eu realmente me reconheci
hoje sabe tudo por causa de uma fala de
um professor porque eu tinha três opções
para poder dar continuidade lá na minha
infância com a literatura de cordel com
a poesia popular eu tinha primeiro a
minha família só que infelizmente a
gente não tinha ninguém envolvido né com
arte com cultura o meu
o convívio social as pessoas ao meu
redor não eram pessoas que estavam
querendo saber sobre arte sobre cultura
mas sim sobre luto de trabalho sabe e o
terceiro a escola na minha época de
escola no colégio municipal álvaro lins
infelizmente eu não tive conhecimento
sobre a literatura de cordel sobre a
cultura da minha região para prender
artes de arte contemporânea arte da
europa e por que não a arte da minha
cidade porque na minha cidade quantos
fazedores de cultura não existe e eu vim
ter conhecimento de 2017 para cá
bom então tudo isso eu devo a um
professor e um professor de literatura
de cordel onde eu vou sempre dizer que
ele é meu mestre nelson lima grande ator
grande poeta grande cordelista aqui da
cidade de caruaru então eu só quero
dizer para vocês vocês professores
educadores pessoas que estão realmente
engajados com a educação da nossa cidade
vocês primeiramente agradecer a vocês
porque são vocês realmente né que levam
o conhecimento para os alunos de sala de
aula mas vocês também tem o poder sabe
um poder lindo o poder de descobrir
talentos que estão dentro de sala de
aula às vezes é um talento que está lá
escondido está só esperando uma
oportunidade sabe e às vezes ele não
sabe nem como se expressar não sabe como
mostrar mas às vezes nos trabalhos
dentro de sala de aula um trabalho
criativo ou até mesmo vocês levando os
alunos para conhecer
e aí os locais de manifestações
culturais de nossa cidade pode despertar
dentro de si aluno outro lado sabe o
lado da cultura da arte que isso é feio
cara você é um voto declamador um
cordelista é nossa arte da minha arte aí
se eu me sinto bem fazendo isso sabe eu
sempre me senti bem eu só tava esperando
alguém diz assim vai lá macho só dá um
empurrão e foi isso professor que me deu
esse fogão e hoje eu faço parte de uma
academia chamada academia caruaru esta
literatura de cordel onde meu convívio
hoje em dia são esses poetas poetas
poetisas que estão sempre levando a arte
a cultura mostrando a literatura de
cordel que estão inspirando e que estão
me ensinando a cada dia
é para isso que eu gostaria de deixar
para vocês que realmente são vocês que
têm o poder de descobrir o outro lado
dos alunos e para mim terminar minha
fala
e eu não poderia deixar de falar um
poema de minha autoria homenageando
tanto alto do moura como o mestre
principal de lá
e eu disse num poema no cordel do barro
que viemos eu falei
e o mundo no seu início não tinha
população nosso deus com sua força o
poder da criação do bairro criou o homem
modelando ele na mão e com isso a
produção de gente só foi crescendo os
anjos trazendo barro nosso deus e a
mexendo e assim de instante instante
muita gente ia nascente e do bairro foi
fazendo do jeito que lhe convém se
tratando em quantidade ele fez foi muito
além pois fez homem fez mulher e fez
menino também trabalhando ainda hoje
seja de noite ou de dia como um bom
trabalhador nosso deus já merecia
descansar as suas mãos ter aposentadoria
mas um dia deus cansou mesmo poder
divino e para lhe ajudar foi chamar um
nordestino e foi logo o rei do bairro
nosso mestre vitalino ele viu que
vitalino tinha muita qualidade pois lá
no alto do moura fez boneca em
quantidade mas somente o que faltava era
a vida de verdade é
e vitalina é o gerente principal do
bairro e da produção da mansão celestial
todo ser do barro feito ele é quem dá o
aval mesmo assim a produção continuar
aumentar vitalino desse a deus alguém
tem que me ajudar eu preciso de mais um
para poder complementar com sua
sabedoria deus diz pode escolher se na
terra tem alguém que você queira trazer
então chama ele para cá que ele aqui vou
acolher no mundo não tinha outra que ele
fosse escolher um cabra de confiança
para no bairro mexer severino vitalino
foi no céu também viver hoje a fábrica
está completa no setor da criação nosso
pai celestial tá na administração
sivirino e vitalino estão lá na produção
diga alto do moura veio aumentar-lhe
muito obrigado a
e aí